at Coventry Crown Court she can bring us
the very latest Adele tell us about
these sentences
the judge has just passed sentence for
work has been given a sentence of 27
years and we've been told that she will
serve a minimum of 17 for the
manslaughter of her son and also four
counts of child cruelty her partner Dirk
Howell has been given a life sentence
and been told that he will serve a
minimum of 32 years and that includes
murder and those four counts the same
four counts of child cruelty as well
when he delivered his sentence the judge
described the pair as sadistic he
described Alfie's death as violent and
brutal he said that between the years
2019 and 2021 that Alfie had been
subjected to repeated acts of violence
and cruelty when he was dunked or at
times thrown in cold baths and submerged
his head gripped under the water so
tightly on either side of his face that
it left bruises in places where it is
very hard to bruise the judge also said
to Scott that she agreed in her witness
statement in her testimony that that
would amount to effectively torture
he also said that the pair used to wake
Elfie up in the early hours of the
morning put him out in the garden and
repeatedly throw jugs of cold water over
him Alfie was often seen outside the
house in cold weather one time in boxer
shorts another time screaming to be let
back in Neighbors had raised their
concerns with the police and Social
Services in the months leading up to his
death one neighbor describes in a 999
call that she could hear a child being
hurt in the bath now the judge also went
into detail about
how calculated the pair were in their
decisions to enforce this behavior on to
Alfie in an attempt to control him he
said that he had more than 50 injuries
to his body
injuries to his head and that they had
been he'd been subjected to those within
a few days of his death he was found and
responsive on February the 18th 2021 in
a bath his mother and her partner had
tried to cover it up Dirk Howell had
fled to the nearby train station and
Carla Scott had tried to claim that her
son had drowned by accident in the bath
he said the judge that this was not the
quiet death that she had portrayed
instead it was a violent and brutal
death what will happen now we're
expecting the police to make a statement
it was very emotional the scenes in
court today we expect the police to make
a statement from where we go from now
though there is a safeguarding review
underway with some serious questions to
be answered over the contact that police
and Social Services had with Alfie and
his family in the years before his death
and also it emerged during the trial
that social services had even considered
taking him away from his mother in the
year before he died so seriously
questions to answer and we expect that
in due course